hey yo I saw knock I sent work of build  once it took him four hours just to fit  one wide-body flare folks came and left  none artistic mind goes forward with  perfection and the knock I signed every  panel was a single brush stroke it was a  masterpiece precisely why I'm worried if  you'll never come don't worry he'll kill  me  miss miss miss miss miss - well [ __ ]  yo guys some big names in town let's get  out there and get noticed man you just  asked Lina ultimate red seriously this  is no me off the hook  Oh  what are we waiting for  again calm  Oh  we're gonna get walking  back then nothing  Oh  right  one everybody talking about  consider yourself noticed we'll be in  touch